[Music]
voices of service the vocal quartet made
up of past and present military service
members gave us chills with their
touching performance during Tuesday's
semi-finals on America's Got Talent
[Applause]
[Music]
music is the universal language and
that's what our goal is to spread that
message of love and hope it's okay that
you're hurting but we're here to help
you heal guest judge Queen Latifah felt
their energy on a personal level I think
about my mom telling me when she would
have to wake my father up out of his
nightmares from Vietnam I have a lot of
family members who were veterans and who
are serving right now when they come
home they need to be supported 100% and
we really need to recognize that they
they're living with a lot of things and
you know my dad sat me down one day and
explained that to me you know explain to
me some of the things that he was going
through and why there were so many
challenges in our life and so I
understand it and I understand that what
voices the service is doing really
really can go a long way in a person's
life it just makes you think that you're
you're making an impact you know it when
you see it and you see the response you
feel like okay they're getting it
equally impactful the Detroit youth
choir you go swaggie up there
I started off crying and I never stopped
coming from Detroit they think that we
can't bring a lot and that you know
we're just um bringing their kids but
for us to come here and show our talent
to the world we're just showing that
Detroit is much more than the city of
cars ten-year-old opera singing
sensation Iman beitia stole our hearts
once again
[Music]
it's crazy it's not going that I made it
this far and it's just such a great
journey what would it mean to you to be
in the finale it would be great you'll
be like a dream come true and when it
comes to dancing the unbeatable gave us
more reasons to believe their name quite
literally
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys really really brought down the
house really pressures rise for us and
yes in the end we did well and they
loved it how distorted you guys are fun
[Music]